on a entendu le train maintenant faisons
pas attention à ses habitudes avant le 6
juillet 2013
pascal charest a tout perdu ses deux
filles âgées de 4 et 9 ans ainsi que
leur mère ont été tués dans la tragédie
de lac mégantic
son histoire est racontée dans la bande
dessinée documentaire lac mégantic la
dernière nuit il y avait plein
d'histoires humaines qu'on avait souvent
entendu mais qu'on pouvait pas raconter
parce qu'on avait pas les images pour la
faire on récit touchant qui nous plonge
au coeur de cette nuit tragique avec
beaucoup d'humanité et de sensibilité
même le choix du bleu fait partie de
cette décision là le choix du rose ou
quand c'est l'explosion c'est pas un
orangé comme cette nuit là et c'est pas
du noir non plus parce que il ya quand
même une douceur à les raconter cette
histoire lui qui durant deux ans elles
ont multiplié les entrevues avec les
survivants pour retranscrire le plus
fidèlement possible le fil des
événements on entendu tellement de
choses sur lac-mégantic mais parfois ça
devient un peu floue qu'est ce qui s'est
passé dans cette nuit là pourquoi c'est
arrivé
je pense que la bande dessinée le décrit
d'un renard mais on voit aussi toutes
les histoires humaines qu'on a tenté de
regrouper ensemble
le résultat est poignant troublant mais
nécessaire je trouve que ce très très
près des réalités
en même temps c'est un hymne des mauvais
souvenirs andré turcotte n'oubliera
jamais cette nuit funeste chauffeur de
taxi c'est lui qui raccompagnait le
conducteur du train avant le début de la
catastrophe il était tout près de la
scène lorsque le train a déraillé
participer à ce projet relever pour lui
du devoir de mémoire est importante pour
oublier
je crois que ça nous aide pas oublié
la bd lac mégantic la dernière nuit est
disponible sur le site internet de radio
canada
et si nabli alexandre chartier radio
canada lac mégantic
[Musique]